why do they think that if they come from
an evolutionary background
because evolution just is all about what
works and what works
who cares about what's true true in the
in the materialist sense
objective i agree and and i should say
um there are
many of my colleagues and friends like
steve pinker um a good colleague
and long time friend who clearly
understands
that natural selection does not in
general favor
true beliefs right and he's got a a
brilliant paper
um a published um called
so how does the mind work it's a
wonderful paper so if you look up steve
pinker so how does the mind work
he he gives in that paper five good
reasons for
why evolution will not lead us to have
true
beliefs in general um
and also real robert trevors has
argued you know brilliantly on
evolutionary grounds that there are
reasons why we should be deeply
self-deceived we the best
liar the best the most convincing liar
in social situations is the one who
believes his own lie
and so there are selection pressures for
us to be deeply deceived
now in trevor's case however he then
even though he understands that aspect
of evolution and
leading to false beliefs when it came to
perception trevor's
still believed and wrote that
seeing the structure of reality as it is
would make you more fit
and that's the argument that most people
believe it's
the argument goes like this those of our
ancestors
who saw reality more accurately
had a competitive advantage over those
who saw the world less accurately
a new competitive advantage in the you
know the the basic
activities of life feeding fighting
fleeing and mating right
and therefore those who saw more
accurately were more likely to pass on
their genes
that code for the more accurate
perceptions
and therefore we can be quite confident
that we may not see all of the truth
but we see those aspects of the truth
that we need to survive
and that kind of argument completely
persuades most of my
my colleagues it apparently persuaded
trivers because he wrote that art you
know yeah it's more fit to see reality
as it is
it didn't persuade pinker although
pinker in the in that paper that i
the brilliant paper that i mentioned you
know so how does the mind work
he does at the at the end of his
discussion of the five
reasons uh why evolution wouldn't
lead to to true beliefs he does make an
exception for everyday middle-sized
objects
and for the quotidian beliefs of of our
friends the everyday quotation beliefs
are
so he he he doesn't explain why he makes
those exceptions
but he does make those two exceptions
and so i'm really focusing on that
exception about everyday middle-sized
objects yeah i'm saying
that our perception of everyday
middle-sized objects
is also not an example of a true belief
it's just an example of something as you
said that's
fit enough to keep you alive